[Music]
guys I'm just gonna come out and say it
eSports is filled with some absolute
units
from road hog to birdie Gragas to
winston i am simply in awe of these
thick and pumped eSports lads that's why
today we're giving you the best of the
biggest by ranking the top 10 plays from
eSports thickest characters let's get
into it you've had to start this list
off with a big lad showing he can stay
quick on his feet during the 2014 na LCS
summer split CLG Seraph was stalking his
prey in the jungle looking to make quick
work of LM Q's Gragas well this big lad
was having none of it after taking a few
Spears that Gragas turns the fight
around and belly slam Seraph back into
his tower to complete the outplay coming
in at number 9 on our list is an epic
comeback moment from Tekken's large
robotic boy jack 7 it really felt like
we were looking at a bracket reset at
NorCal regionals 2018 as Coogan's devil
Jin had Saints Jack 7 on the ropes but
the biggest boy on our list decided that
he would not go down easily 20 seconds
left
[Applause]
Manji corporation really builds their
voice thick don't they there may not be
a thicker lad in league of legends than
tahm Kench which is why this can't play
from world's 2018 has to come in at
number eight on our list during the
tournaments play in stage g2 esports
what deed showed us why benching the
Kench is a bad move by saving his mid
laner not once once again saving the day
with the Tom catch ultimate you gotta
love the use that interaction sure this
champion might be larger than most but
that just means he's got a bigger heart
coming in at number seven we've got one
of the most jungling characters around
that's right we're talking about road
hog during the overwatch league's first
two years the world's best players have
showed us just how quick this big boy
can be in the right hands so let's take
a moment to appreciate some of the best
hooks that this thick tank has landed
for this money though now is looking
really strong at the sir here they
stopped fusion from fully tapping at the
ball but they actually managed to pull
ahead here gladiators just another but
that takes time and I think that'll fuel
they need some patience because this is
not going stager they tried to push it
it wasn't work here's a minute of the
fails yeah it what really was and then
coming into junkie town Florida may have
looked from a set of impressive hooks to
one that is a little more exploitative
our number six play comes courtesy of
dota twos thickest hero punch and if you
haven't guessed it already we're talking
about natus Vincere famed fountain hook
strategy from ti3 still hasn't even been
used there's over run all the way back
to the base
cleaned up by the fountain we actually
just saw the chin punch combo at the
international that happened for the
uninitiated this quasi wombo combo sees
Pudge Hulk in enemy just as Chen's test
of fate is counting down twitch resulted
in some poor soul getting hooked all the
way back to the fountain where they
would be greeted by instant death
[Applause]
this is what you call one seriously the
[ __ ] is broken as [ __ ] I think it's safe
to say that overwatch is a game built
around big boys after all the tanks like
rinehart and winston have been the
linchpins of competitive play since the
game's release so number five we harken
back to one of the world's most
aggressive Reinhart players Vancouver
Titans bumper now most of these thick
characters we have on this list give off
a sort of bull in a china shop kind of
vibe but against the Shanghai Dragons
bumper shows us that big boys can be
just as sneaky as their scum soo this
guy has been doing this for ages and
still people don't look both ways coming
in at number four is a thick boy known
for his massive dunks
no we're not talking about Shaq we're
talking about one of the rifts biggest
lads the hand of noxus darius and few
plays in league of legends history
better exemplified the beauty and
carnage of a darius dunk than this
world's 2015 group stage play
courtesy of boys stroke men both
sideways pushing for c92 they have that
tar behind them for safety not a seating
mitt so the using triple pressure on all
the ladies here here's the jump it is a
two meadow to get the balls
stinkies art there's a turret alive but
they gotta be careful a big backpack
event the killer gotta does here goes
down as well but the Ducks are coming
through a Dumbo Guilford balls a triple
that's what season pick interiors cloud9
three members alive one an aggressive
use of Flash ulti different condition he
knew he would drop in a fight when he
would generate so much damage for resets
on both sneaky involved at number three
we've got yet another example of a
massive character proving that big guys
have a lot of stamina against the L a
valiant fissures Winston sees two
enemies floating high off the map and
out of range of the vertically
challenged but instead of simply
avoiding the Rockets he decides to take
matters going in favor of the gladiators
in another half tried to come through
from hydration on new agility is we know
how
this is a bit ballsy
[Applause]
those more handsome and handsy when it
comes to the Palmer Raids dude is so
goofy after jumping off the map Fisher
pops primal rage to gain an extra jump
and then proceeds to maul both Farah and
mercy down from midair before leaping
back to safety just as his primal runs
out now that's a big boy play if we've
ever seen one taking the runner-up spot
on our list is none other than rank
choose unbelievable run with one of
Tekken's worst and also biggest
characters panda Panda yeah now I'd be
remiss to mention that panda proves that
it's not only big boys that can rise to
the top of the eSports world but big
gals as well with the entire community
doubting him rank to not only play the
off meta character at the 2018 Tekken
World Championship but won the whole
damn thing with his trust by the wall is
gonna go for it again rank chewed
content to wait yes wait he could just
stand his block he doesn't want to take
too many rows has a two round lead the
only thing that's gonna kill him is the
he'll sweep and that's the thing all he
has to do is tap down back and he could
look at this oh heavens be careful of
one more you get outta here
[Applause]
in fact ranches title win with panda was
so monumental we made an entire video
about it sitting atop our list is the
single most lucrative thick play of all
time a place so massive that it turned a
team of dota 2 players into overnight
millionaires of course we're talking
about v6 million dollar echo slam
courtesy of one of dota 2's thickest
boys
Earthshaker evil geniuses were
considered to be one of the best dota 2
teams in the world
heading into ti5 but standing in their
way in the finals were see Dec gaming a
team that had already beat them earlier
in the upper bracket final with eg up to
one in the series see Dec were forced to
rush Roshan to try to turn the tide of
game four and once four members of cec
were nicely packed into the Rosh pit
well we all know what happens next there
is no hook shot there altogether
PPG he comes the ice blasts or any
[Applause]
geniuses and now they will take her
Charlotte
the only alternative is that CDC moved
toward the Rose pit and actually don't
go for it fading expecting that eg want
to check it for on five which would be
very unlikely and then just going for it
instead they just kitchen being clumped
up getting close by - class well guys
there you have it from a gorilla in
space to a giant robot man with a mohawk
those are the best plays from eSports
thickest characters now is there a large
lad making plays out there that you
think we missed in our list let us know
in the comments below and if you're
wouldn't mind hitting that sub button
and making our subscriber count just
that much more thick I'd appreciate it
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up art Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]